how many films have you made for Quentin
Tarantino six six and he puts you in
every movie almost at this point right A
lot of them he's got to you're his go-to
guy he's only made eight you've been in
six well he couldn't find a place for me
and then glorious bastards even I told
him I wanted to be the black French guy
he's no you don't speak French I'm like
I can learn right yeah I need a real a
real Rich French black guy are you
disappointed in him if he doesn't write
you in a role
occurred to me because he had never done
it right except well there was nothing
for me to do and Kill Bill right and I
read it and I read it through twice and
I finally went oh yeah I can be this
piano player guy right and you figure
out where you belong in these films
right yeah I mean I think that's great
to have a relationship with a writer
director like that who who really
believes in you yeah you know what I
mean so when you do hateful eight and
you and you read this script are you
thinking greatness right away or you
can't tell with a Quentin Tarantino
script they're so goddamn dense these
scripts you can tell he's he's a genius
yeah it's like reading a really good
novel or a really good play this this
particular film reads like a very
theatrical piece I mean we actually did
a stage reading of it it could be a play
I actually told him you should take this
and make a Broadway play out of it we
could we could go to the West End in
London and it would work do this thing
for six weeks in London and create a
huge sensation storming the Broadway on
a limited run let's do a ton of money
and get out is he for that he is he's
talking about it but if Queen comes to
that kind of thing but it all depends on
the other people and and when you're
doing a film of his are you thinking
Academy Award nomination because these
films everybody seems to get nominated
who are in his films right they don't
know they don't but you look at Django
only person got nominated was Kristoff
that's true Leo should have been
nominated I definitely should have been
I mean
I can't imagine any character that had a
greater impact see my Criterion seem to
be different than what everybody else's
criteria is what is people who are
voting yeah yeah what is your criteria
uh if there's a character in a
particular film that is impactful that
moves the script along and you leave the
theater wishing you could spend more
time with right Quentin comes up with
[ __ ] for you to do though in these films
right I mean in Django Unchained do a
[ __ ] you had to do in the film they cut
it out it was so despicable right yeah
what did they cut out of that film that
you had to do well I had a I had a
torture scene um I would have seen where
I tortured Django in the barn they got
edited you know really wonderfully I was
kind of burning his nipples off with a
hot poker oh my God it was too
outrageous when you were shooting that
scene did you say to yourself This is a
[ __ ] way this is going to be in the
movie no I don't know when we were
shooting it I was like this is going to
be awesome when people see this do you
get disappointed when they edit these
films and a lot of this wacky [ __ ] they
have you do is not in it yes you do
you're like wait a second I took time to
do it and you know I felt great when I
was doing it and I know what kind of
impact it will have on an audience and
when it's not there it's like oh what
the [ __ ] can you go to Quentin and say
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you I did
you do it well
it was kind of too much you know people
give me enough [ __ ] about my violence
you know I said well
are you gonna put out a director's cut
so this [ __ ] can be in it right you know
because as Despicable as Stephen is in
the film that's the night Stephen right
yeah I don't think that was a character
in Django more impactful than Steven I
mean Steven's pretty much as I told
Quentin the most despicable negro and
cinematic history yeah right he is so
true delicious you've had fun
amount of fun